terminó el culebrón si lo decimos en
jerga de teleseries raúl finalmente los
socialistas ese consejo nacional de 300
miembros se aprobó por 167 votos la
unión de los socialistas para participar
junto a toda la izquierda de cara a las
legislativas de junio y ya es oficial
son 70 circunscripciones hay muchos que
se quejaban justamente de eso el
secretario general del partido libio fue
recordó al final de la votación que en
realidad en apenas 12 circunscripciones
anida algo candidata socialista de las
presidenciales logró más de un 3% así
que básicamente les dijo bueno no nos
quejemos que es bastante lo que nos
están dando y por otro lado él dijo
todos decían cuál era nuestro lugar en
la política pues ya lo tenemos es a la
izquierda y no nos moveremos esto
obviamente como lo hemos hablado toda la
semana ha profundizado la crisis en el
seno del partido socialista muchos
socialistas han dicho que se van a
presentar con candidaturas disidentes ya
les han advertido desde el partido que
van a ser expulsados en caso que lo
hagan esta noche en el informativo de
france
20 horas que es el más importante de la
televisión francesa para hablar
finalmente ya luís melanson va a hablar
sobre el programa de esta unión nada
popular de la nueva unión popular
ecológica y socialista raúl y mañana va
a haber un acto de investidura con todos
los partidos los insumisos los
comunistas los ecologistas están felices
de esta unión también de los socialistas
dicen que por fin el partido se ha
acercado a sus raíces y pasa la página
del quinquenio de françois hollande o
tan criticado en la izquierda raúl